When do you start talking about hope?
Some people think it's immediately a
kind of Pollyanna ish thing,
like,
oh,
it should be hopeful,
or it's kind of a greeting card.
Um,
sentiment.
You go kind of doe wide and start
thinking soft thoughts about how we
should all be hopeful in one another.
And of course there are some important
things to be said in favor of those
kinds of things,
but we think of hope as also an
extremely difficult and important and
foundational sort of state that can be
discussed in ways that aren't.
So saccharin.
One of the interesting things that
philosophers talk about with respect to
hope is of course it's rationality.
So there's a sense in which you can't
hope for everything you can wish for.
Lots of things for which you can't hope.
I can wish that the bears won the
superbowl last year.
Uh,
but I can't hope that they won the
superbowl last year because we know that
they didn't.
And so it seems almost like you're
misusing the word to say,
I hope that they won last year,
or I hope that the weather was different
yesterday than it was.
So there's a kind of semantic content
that suggests that there are rationality
constraints on hope,
which philosophers tried to look at an
analyze.
There's a kind of orthodox account.
People call it the Orthodox account
because most people share it,
uh,
that says that hope involves at least
desiring something and believing that
it's possible.
So in this case,
you wouldn't believe that the weather
yesterday could be different than it
was,
and so you wouldn't believe that's
possible.
And so you can't really hope for it.
So that's that condition that's
constraining the rationality of hope.
And then there's this kind of debate
about what further conditions might be
required.
One thought experiment that people have
discussed frequently is that of the
Shawshank redemption.
So this is a Stephen King short story
that was turned into a film.
You have two characters and,
and read both of them really desire
something to get out of prison.
Both of them regarded as possible.
It's explicit in the story and in the
film,
but somehow one character,
andy is hopeful and says he's hopeful
and that he's acting in such a way as to
make it come about.
Even if he thinks it's extremely
unlikely.
And the other character red says he
can't allow himself to hope.
The fear of disappointment is too great
and will crush him.
So they both meet those conditions.
It's something they really desire and
it's something they believe to be
possible.
And yet one hopes and the other
despairs.
So cases like this make people think,
oh,
we need some other kind of condition to
really explain the difference between
hope and despair.
And that's where some of the debate is
at the moment,
trying to find this elusive third
conditions.
And different people have different
things they want to add to the Orthodox
conception.
My own favored approach,
which I'm in the middle of writing up a
is what I call the focus or attention
account of hope.
Uh,
so it basically says something like the
difference between hope and despair is
the extent to which you're focusing on
the very slim odds of the thing coming
about or whether you're focusing on the
fact that it's possible or that you take
it to be possible.
So if you're focused on the thing as a
possibility under the aspect of its
possibility,
if you want,
then you're hoping for it.
If you're focusing on the fact that it's
incredibly unlikely and the odds are so
such long shot odds,
then you're despairing of it.
So you can desire it in the same way you
can believe that it's possible in the
same way.
And it's this focus that really makes
the difference between hope and despair.
It might even be a kind of spectrum
thing where you can move back and forth.
The focus might be under your control
sometimes other times given the
circumstances or the the strength of the
desire that might not always be under
your control.
So I also kind of talk a little bit
about the way a certain kind of,
if you want,
mindfulness training can lead us to be
more hopeful people cultivating the
virtue of hope by learning how to focus
on something under the aspect of its
possibility rather than allowing our
focus or attention to always drift
towards the fact that it's so unlikely.
Um,
you can even hear this in the way that
someone might say something about what
they hope for or despair of.
So in the Andy and red case,
Andy might say,
I know that it's really unlikely,
but at least it's possible and sort of
focus on the possibility.
That's the hopeful sort of approach.
And Red might say,
I know that it's possible,
but it's really unlikely.
Same desire,
same estimation of the probabilities,
but you can even hear in the way it's
stated,
I kind of difference in attitude that I
take to be the essential difference
between hope and despair.
So one more locus of discussion is the
relationship between hope,
optimism and action.
I think a lot of people regard hope in a
way as unserious because it gets
detached from action in a certain way.
So hope is something that you do when
you can't do anything else.
It's the kind of curse that is left in
Pandora's box because you still have it,
even though there's nothing else you can
do with respect to achieving the goal
and question.
I'm just hoping for it.
It seems possible,
but there's not much I can do.
I'm just sort of passively hoping.
Um,
that obviously seems like a bit of a
character of the way in which hope might
actually work.
And so we're curious,
and people in both psychology,
sociology,
or other social sciences as well as
philosophers and religious studies
people in our project think about the
way in which hope underwrites action,
hope manifested itself in action.
Hope is the result of actions.
So agency and hope is a really
interesting set of issues that we think
is underdeveloped.